one distant chapter in our nation's long
history suddenly acquired renewed
interest this year just over 100 years
ago the Spanish flu pandemic raged
across the United States and around the
world many of the strategies used to
deal with it are the same ones were
using today Elizabeth Palmer has more in
1918 World War one was finally ending
millions were on the move soldiers
refugees and immigrants all helping to
spread the so called Spanish flu it
infected one in three people on earth
Loras Bunny is the author of Pale Rider
and it killed an estimated 50 to 100
million people which equates to two
point five to five percent of the global
population at that time covered 19
attacks the lungs so did the Spanish flu
vanna's now there was no cure and no
vaccine just common sense prescriptions
like fresh air these women employees of
Britain's War Department were sent on
regular walks to ward off the virus in
San Francisco even courtrooms moved
outside an antique Ovid masks in 2020
aren't much different from the ones
people wore a century ago but 1918 was
different from 2020 in one crucial way
ordinary people weren't told very much
why were the authorities censoring
information about the outbreak the idea
that you couldn't trust the public with
too much information because they would
panic and run riot and then you wouldn't
be able to control them so people
blindly followed rules that killed them
especially soldiers on crowded troop
ships who spread the virus around the
world
it wasn't until 1920 that the worst
pandemic in history ended as kovat 19
will do - eventually it will just fizzle
out but the question is how long will
that take
and how many people are going to fall
ill and die in the meantime the lesson
of 1918 is social distancing and good
hygiene do work the future is up to us
for CBS this morning Saturday I'm
Elizabeth Palmer in London
back to basics and so many times Jeff
we've been saying this in so many ways
but if you don't learn from the past you
will repeat it obviously a loose quote
of that yeah imagine that common sense
working a hundred years ago working
today and working 100 years from now not
too complicated Dana thank you very much